i'm doing another smoothie from my meal
plan today and guys i'm down
wait
six pounds so today's smoothie is mango
banana and strawberry and there are like
pros and cons of this meal plan so a pro
is that i really like all the food but a
con so far has been that i have to cook
a lot but i don't really mind cooking
too much it's funny though on this meal
plan
since i started it i have been playing
so well for volleyball i literally had
the best game i've ever played in my
entire life the other day i had 22 kills
and two errors which is a really good
like hitting percentage and i was
thinking like damn i should have tried
eating healthier a long time ago
right and i'm wanting to do more like
vlogs for you guys but my life is so
boring these days maybe it's not boring
i do a live youtube show for my
apartment which is kind of fun i do
guitar lessons every day i'm getting my
master's degree and i'm playing pro
volleyball so it's like a lot but
i don't know it's kind of like what do i
show you of my day-to-day life anyways
so the nutrition guy told me to use
kefir milk and he said it's like
healthier than regular milk and almond
milk is apparently bad for you
okay so this is the final product and
let's see if i like it
oh that's fire that's good